[Music]
welcome back everybody it's charlie we
have a whole bunch of new fantastic four
and x-men stuff to talk about
the russo's kevin feige were clarifying
a lot of comments talking about
the future movies they were planning on
making so we'll break it all down
and because of all the spider-man news
marvel just doubled down
on all the fantastic four and x-men
characters they got access to
in a big way sony even specifically
cited that as a point of contention
during their negotiations for the new
contract so if you're brand new to the
channel
be sure to subscribe to get all the
easter egg videos this new giveaway
stuff i'll explain at the end of the
video
so breaking it all down top 10 style
kevin bogey just clarified some of his
comments about fantastic four and x-men
since the comic-con and d23 marvel phase
four announcements
now the russos have also chimed in too
but starting with number 10
kevin feige confirmed they were going
with a very different looking
x-men team for their first marvel x-men
standalone movie
still a couple years away i will talk
about release dates in a second
but he wasn't talking about x-men
characters crossing over into other
movies
because he does refer to them as mutants
because you have people like deadpool
there'll be a lot of other mutants
popping up in other people's mcu movies
during phase four and phase five before
you see the very first marvel
x-men film nine namor and black panther
two is the best example of that
he's referred to as the first mutant in
the comics as a reference to the fact
that he debuted in the comics
before the traditional x-men characters
within the canon of the comics there are
mutants that are older than namor like
apocalypse but in real life namor was
the first to debut
he's a slam dunk black panther villain
especially now that they lost access to
the spider-man characters if craven was
potentially going to be a villain in
black panther 2
definitely not going to be one of the
villains now they've had so much beep
between the two of them in the last 10
years in the comics i can't wait to see
what they do
with that character and how they
differentiate him
from aquaman including atlantis because
technically atlantis
and like the greek gods are things from
real world mythology that you can't
copyright so that means that both marvel
and dc can use those concepts but marvel
will have to do something different than
what the aquaman movie did with atlantis
eight when kevin feige talks about a
very different x-men team debuting
what he means is you've seen the x-men
team form for the first time
in x-men first class typically those
movies were built around the
relationship between professor x
and magneto magneto was a world war ii
survivor that was a huge part of his
backstory and his motivation
first class took place in the 1960s so
that they could loosely tie the
continuity together james bond style
with the brian singer x-men movies much
to the chagrin
of everyone trying to figure out the
timeline then you have characters like
wolverine that kind of took over the
franchise for a while with his
popularity
kevin feige's first team will have to
tell that origin story differently
and it will be set in present day after
avengers end game
kitty pride is a really good example of
an old school fan favorite character
from the comics that will probably get a
lot more love with this new
modern reinterpretation and they'll all
get
much more comic book accurate costumes
seven the eternals movie is taking the
mcu cosmic in a much bigger way than
they've ever gone before
that's in service of a lot of the larger
fantastic four
characters in concepts galactus is the
best example of that
just an awesome slam dunk celestial
villain and then potential ally
in bigger conflicts fantastic four is
one of those franchises that shares a
lot in common with the doctor strange
movies because of the way they use
science to explain magical energy
dark energy in the multiverse but also
more legit sci-fi concepts like the
celestials
cosmic powers like the powers unlocked
in scarlet witch by the mind stone
that's why marvel is doing the doctor
strange multiverse of madness movie in
the eternals movie before they do the
fantastic four movie
six how they going to handle those
origins where those characters been this
whole time
i already did a similar video about the
eternals explaining why they didn't
fight in the final battle during
adventures end game
because the way kevin feige explains it
in the marvel cinematic universe
they've been around this whole time we
just haven't known it so why didn't they
help out in any of the previous
conflicts
the reason why the x-men haven't been
around is a little bit different than
the eternals but it's all about the idea
of the eternals cosmic energy
in the multiple infinity gauntlet snaps
on earth releasing
more cosmic energy in what the
celestials did on earth
millions of years ago to modify humanity
leading to the activation of the x gene
and all the x-men characters
there was a great avengers 1 million bc
story that explains how the eternals
origins are also tied to the origins of
the x-men
odin leads a team of avengers during
that era when he's a much younger
version of himself
they fight a celestial that's gone mad
and come to earth to die
its cosmic blood leeches into the soil
and eventually through the food chain
and over eons
it gives humanity their ex gene and any
other kind of biological powers you see
in the marvel universe
it's just a way of explaining how you
have so many special people with powers
popping up on planet earth
more so than any other planet in the
universe five talking about the russos
doing more marvel movies
after avengers end game they did a bunch
of interviews where they said they were
so wiped
from the years that they put into
avengers infinity war in avengers end
game they just needed a flat out break
from doing marvel movies
they were just at a film festival
recently promoting the indie film they
produced
and they said that they already now want
to come back to marvel to do x-men and
fantastic four movies
they even specified what kind of stories
ben grimm the thing was a really
was one of my favorites fantastic four
would be really fun to play around with
wolverine um you know great lakes
avengers
we always joke there's a lot of talk
around that uh
like a younger faction of superheroes
coming through
what of the younger marvel lot would you
like to
explore potentially certainly the young
avengers would be fun
i mean take spider-man as an example but
whenever you put responsibility
on a teen or a child it adds a much more
dramatic component to the notion of
being a superhero so i think
there's a lot of interesting choices
that can be made with younger heroes
they said specifically john burn era
x-men in fantastic four
that's late 70s to mid 80s x-men
fantastic four comics which funny enough
includes x-men the dark phoenix saga
now they've also mentioned doing a
wolverine movie and doing other avengers
secret wars movies or a series of secret
wars movies they pitched that as a six
film
series for john burns fantastic four run
widely considered
a second golden age for the team he
wrote that brun after he finished x-ben
even though in the mcu movies
we're gonna be watching the fantastic
four movies gonna happen before the
x-men movie
for those of you asking new mutants
technically doesn't count even though
that's really an x-men film
there were a lot of rumors about what
marvel is going to do with that movie
they're still trying to figure out if
they want to spend more money to do more
reshoots because that gets kind of
expensive
the bigger rumor was that they were
removing a lot of brian singer x-men
references and characters from it so
that it'd be easier to bring those new
mutants characters into the mcu later
if the movie is successful generally the
buzz for it doesn't seem like it's too
bad so 50 50 odds whether or not it
winds up being just a one-off vestige of
fox marvel
three release dates there was a recent
rumor that marvel was fast-tracking
fantastic four after all this spider-man
business
for a 2022 release that isn't that far
off and they haven't announced any other
dates for that year outside of black
panther 2 which is may
2022 so i don't know how much i believe
the fantastic four rumor but that was
before
all the spider-man news happened so
they're doubling down on all the new
stuff it is totally possible we can get
a fantastic four movie by 2022
but they would have to publicly announce
it next year start casting the
characters and hire
all their crew to get it out by 2022
two the rumored release date for the
next x-men movie is supposedly 2023
and just like with that fantastic four
release date rumor
take it with a grain of salt but it does
sound plausible enough
look we have all these spider-man plans
that we can't enact now but we have all
these brand new characters so why don't
we bring in the biggest ones as fast as
possible
in number one meet your newest big
avengers villain in doctor doom
because before all that spider-man
fallout norman osborne seemed like he
was being poised to become the new
anti-iron man of the mcu
spider-man far from home was integrated
very deeply with what was going to be
happening during marvel phase 4
and there's this whole idea of a vacuum
left by iron man who's going to pick up
his legacy
it seemed like originally kevin feige
had intended a twist that norman osborne
would wind up being the person to try
and fill that hole and it would be this
dark term for the mcu and everyone would
have to rally together
but now that sounds like that's going to
be doctor doom he's a man of science and
magic he works perfectly in almost
any of the avengers a-list spin-off
movies he's worked with doctor strange a
bunch of times he's tried to take over
iron man's legacy after civil war two he
even refashioned some of iron man's
armor into a dr
doom iron man suit and he was a huge
black panther villain a long time ago
everybody wants them that vibranium
gotta upgrade those doom bots
so post all your fantastic four and
x-men theories in the comments if there
are any other big news updates about
them
actually doing fantastic four and x-men
stuff i will totally do a video about it
there's a new amazon giveaway going on
right now all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber and just leave your
best fantastic four
theory on the comments below
congratulations to evan disastrous
you're the giveaway winner from my last
big marvel video please email me on the
about page of my channel so i can get
your details
everybody click here for that wolverine
vs hulk video and click here for that
brand new rick and morty season 4
teaser trailer thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome
i'll see you guys tonight
[Music]
you